i seriously go bananas for this guy
that's why he's perfect for banana mores
bananas banana boys now i'm gonna go eat
this banana
thank you mitzi love you aren't you glad
she didn't say banana again
i am well how are you
how how are you i am
stressed obviously this pandemic it's
just
building just the fear the waiting
i feel like just give it to me already
you know just let this be oh like i feel
like the skinny kid
who's playing dodge ball and he's like
well somebody just hit me with the ball
so i can sit down already and have a
juice box and get on with my life
i'm walking around that helps walking
the streets of venice
and uh looking for i'm alone half the
stores are empty
and then yesterday i look across the
street and there's a woman
in a clothing store and all of a sudden
she just starts waving at me
and i'm looking at her and i'm like
and so i start waving back and i'm
walking towards her and she's waving
and i'm waving and then i get closer
and i see that she's got a rag in her
hand and she's cleaning the window
and i was so bummed out i just went and
i bought some ice cream
and i wiped it all over that window
the other thing that helps you got to
find something for your own head some
people do crossword puzzles
i run that helps people see
it hurts i'm not in shape and so when i
run
i actually am in pain and i feel like
i'm going to die
like literally i'm dying i'm running
down the street people see the fear in
my eyes
and they don't think i'm exercising they
think i'm fleeing something scary
people start running next to me looking
over their shoulders like
is there a is there a monster what's
happening
uh i watch a lot of sports with my son
that's what you do when you have a son
it's very hard to be vulnerable when you
have a son i don't know how many guys
can relate to that
but you want to communicate you want to
connect and so sports is a safe way
of almost playing out whatever your
dynamic is that's going on between you
you can almost play it out on the screen
what's going on in the game
like i remember watching the super bowl
a couple years ago
with my son owen he's like 17.
i don't know i gotta check and we're
watching the game
and i'm like wow it seems like um
seems like tom brady's having a hard
time lately
and he's like yeah
yeah he kind of is i said well
what do you think is going on with him
and he goes well
i think sometimes just coach belichick
is just pushing him a little too hard
well that's probably because belichick
sees how much potential
tom brady has and he wants to just make
sure he helps them reach that full
potential well it's too much
he should back off
well you know tom brady is a free agent
next year and then i
i guess he can figure out where he's
going to get his own money from
i can't even get over how much talent
this person has
kind of unfair give a little to the rest
of us